thank you
[Music]
we are taking a look back at some of the
most powerful and haunting images from
September 11 2001 video from Lower
Manhattan shows both the horror and the
heroes who risk their lives for others
this morning we're hearing from a CBS
News cameraman and an audio technician
about what they witnessed when they
rushed to Ground Zero 20 years ago much
of the following footage shot by our
cameraman is disturbing some viewers I
find it hard to watch
it's actually a beautiful day I remember
the blue sky
pretty striking clearest Blue Sky sunny
beginning Taste of fall in the air we
understand that there has been a plane
crash on the southern tip of Manhattan
my name is Mark leganka 911 I worked for
CBS News as a cameraman
[Music]
we pulled up and I would say within 20
minutes or so the first Tower fell
with the sound of a crashing freight
train Beau whites is my sound partner
for the day we're told a small plane
crashed into one of the buildings but we
didn't know any details other than that
what happened
something came to
collapse I need some water
part of the building collapsed
it got immensely quiet after the first
Tower fell
and I remember law enforcement fire
fighters telling us to stay back
Mark said wait here and he ran in
there bro
there's a woman in a wheelchair and
and uh I got her in the strap wheelchair
and just carried her down the steps and
carried her down 68 floors man
after the first building came down
there's very little color in anything
that you're looking at okay even the
shrubs and the greenery is all gray
[Music]
thank you do you know where everybody's
going
I remember the crackling of the fire
looking up at the second tower
and then I remember
as it started to come down it sounded
like Jets were flying overhead so I just
tilted up to see them to videotape them
and it wasn't Jets it was the tower was
coming down
I knew the smoke was coming towards me
but the reason you don't turn and drop
the camera run away is you're there to
document what happened
foreign
[Applause]
what happened
it collapsed
the top floors collapsed down
the sword brought blow and then ran like
hell thank God
I'm 69 but I can still run
Trap Back Then
when the second tower fell
I thought that La ganga had probably
bought it that uh that was it
and I was thinking about having to speak
with his wife about that
but I remained hopeful and I moved
forward
to find him
and at some point
Mark came walking out covered Head To
Toe with the dust of the Tower and a
gash on his forehead but he came out and
we washed them off and kept going
what'd you see everything that's a chaos
it's just chaos out here it really is so
the Twin Towers full it was beeping all
around us the sounds we heard all around
us of beeping
were alarms from the clothing or on the
person's the fire fighters
the beeping is fire I didn't know this
at the time but it's a sound you can
never forget it's a firefighter down
alarm and it means there are
firefighters trapped
[Music]
nice
[Music]
there are people who did amazing things
that day I literally just videotaped
what they were doing
do you have survivor's count
no yes I I don't know how to answer that
yeah I mean I don't think anyone that
was there that day doesn't feel guilty
that they were able to go home people
went towards the building to save people
I just videotaped so I feel pretty
guilty about that I really don't think
he can indict himself for doing his job
that day
I think he did a service to us all by
continuing to go forward
I hope we're all a little bit better
because we're able to see
[Music]
what people do in that kind of situation
and all I saw was people helping each
other I never saw anything else there
was a time immediately after the towers
fell when there was a cohesiveness in
the city you could feel it
still the greatest City I mean I know
sounds glib to say that but I mean it is
with kovid with 911 with everything
that's happened in the city it just it
continually reinvents itself
[Music]
Mark it's hard to speak about it's very
hard to see and and those are two
individuals I've worked with a ton over
the years and I am just learning now
about their experiences on that day it's
taken this anniversary yeah we haven't
always will recognized those in uniform
in the civilians who were heroic in that
moment but I don't think we talk about
people who would help cameras documented
documented these moments you know the
pain and also the best part of people
because we were helping each other okay
yeah we need some more of that our
thanks to Shannon Louis brand who's one
of our top producers here put that
together it's very difficult to put that
piece together with no track and capture
the way she did all of the emotion all
of the trauma all of the pain yet at the
end of the day still the the light of
people still saying we're going to get
through this and somehow make it through
yeah we have but it's still very very
difficult I still think about the
families that are suffering today no
doubt yeah right and New York's still
the greatest city on earth the
resilience
will allow it to bounce back we'll be
right back